from the second one I took one of
Anakin's braids he had that little like
braid hanging down then I lost it you
know so that's not very helpful hey
there GQ I'm Natalie Portman and today
I'm going undercover on the Internet
it's actually me
let's check Twitter
[Music]
I don't think we appreciate Thor nearly
enough for just how immensely weird it
was Sir Anthony Hopkins Idris Elba
Natalie Portman fresh off an Oscar win
Kat Dennings as the comic relief
directed by Sir Kenneth Branagh what a
lineup for a superhero flick thanks
that's really nice I also feel like so
much of it is funny because they had
such trouble with like schedules that a
lot of people who aren't there at the
same time so we'd also be like doing
scenes with some guy that looked a lot
like Anthony Hopkins but wasn't Anthony
Hopkins but wearing his wig in costume
and saying his line so there was a lot
of unusual stuff in the filming process
of that too I thought it was so cool to
have Kenneth Brana doing a Marvel movie
because he had been so renowned for his
Shakespeare adaptations and it seemed so
ripe to take this like Norse mythology
and treat it with that kind of
Shakespearean family Saga feeling so it
always seemed like an inspired choice
is Natalie Portman really can ballet
sentence structure I love that I
definitely learned a lot of ballet for
Black Swan I can't do it now at all I'm
quite out of shape for that now and also
of course I'm nowhere close to a
professional ballet dancer but I can a
little ballet
does anyone else ever think about how
weird it is that Ashton Kutcher who is
married to Mila Kunis did no strings
attached with Natalie Portman the same
year Mila Kunis did friends with
benefits of Justin Timberlake the movies
had the same basic premise how is it not
weird
it's weird it's totally weird correct
I wonder are we going to see Natalie
Portman as Jackie oh again hmm
excellent question I I cannot reveal the
answer to that
Instagram
what's on your summer reading list I'm
reading the postcard by Anne burest I
want to read the biography of X then
I'll try and find
a mystery or something fun to dig into
as well I'm into everything actually
I've been really into like kind of
nature science books recently I loved an
immense World by Ed young that was my
last great when I read I also love
Gathering Moss by Robin wall Kimmer I
get kind of nerdy with my like books
about nature I love it thanks for doing
this work I've dreamed of a league like
this since the 80s you rock lifelong
dream to live through this moment for
women's soccer that's so nice I'm so
happy to hear that I feel the same way I
was so inspired as a teenager watching
the 99ers and then to get to be part of
it today and that was also so inspired
by the last women's world club with
Megan rapino and Alex Morgan Kristen
press just leading the way for women's
equality while killing in on the fields
I love in soccer that one player's goal
is a win for the entire team and I think
that's such an amazing model for women
where we've so often been socialized to
be pitted against each other and so that
kind of win for all mindset is
incredible and then also it's the most
popular sport in the world and in the US
we have the best female players in the
world so why wouldn't we capitalize on
that with our home League
okay from Reddit
say what you want about the prequels but
the costume design was amazing it was
amazing this one is pretty incredible
it's got such like kind of Japanese
elements from the second one I took one
of Anakin's braids he had that little
like braid hanging down and I lost it
you know so that's not very helpful
any chance that Padme Natalie Portman
returns to Star Wars her character
really deserves it with the way she was
treated in Revenge of the Sith and
overall importance for the OT story I
have no information on this no one's
ever asked me to return but I'm open to
it
did Tiger with TD forget Natalie Portman
was in Star Wars he says he did because
he like asked me if I wanted to be in a
Star Wars movie
and I was like I was I thought he was
joking he's such a joker that I thought
it was a joke and then afterwards he
said in some interview that he like was
cringing afterwards
what movies ending leads you wanting a
sequel but at the same time you're
afraid of a sequel because it would ruin
the movie's ending in Legacy a sequel to
Leon the Professional where Natalie
Portman is all grown up and carrying the
torchico called Matilda the professional
I I completely agree it would be really
cool to have a sequel but the first one
is so beloved by so many people that I
wouldn't want to mess it up
YouTube
[Music]
Natalie Portman was my favorite actress
and now she's also my favorite rapper
that's so nice I really enjoyed doing
the wrap it was a way to kind of show a
different side of me than people had
thought and poked fun at myself a little
bit they just kept me like be angry or
just angry or keep screaming more anger
and um the direction was very surprising
I didn't know to expect that
I would be so Starstruck if I saw
Natalie Portman I wonder who she gets
Star Struck by well that's so nice to be
Starstruck by me I'm a star struck by
these soccer players so when I get to
meet Kristen press or Abby Wambach I'm
in awe of them but also I get really
star-struck by writers I got to meet
Rachel cusp recently and Deborah Levy
and I get really in awe of them because
writing beautifully is just like the
greatest gift
now on to Cora
was Natalie Portman okay being written
out of the MCU I wasn't aware that it
was written out but
um I feel like I participated in three
films at the MCU so I'm very proud of
that and happy I got to do that
does Natalie Portman speak fluent
Japanese no I wish I did I took Japanese
in high school I can like count and like
say basic greetings but unfortunately I
do not speak fluent Japanese I speak
Hebrew fluently and I speak French okay
okay from chat GPT
you have starred in many popular films
throughout your career which character
has been your favorite to portray and
why Wow Chachi BT is boring I love
playing Jackie Kennedy that was fun
because I felt like she just had this
great wit and wisdom you've been an
advocate for various social and
political causes such as animal rights
and environmentalism what motivated you
to get involved in activism how do you
use your platform to make a positive
impact this is like um
like pageant questions when I care about
something I want to
talk about it and want to make it better
I feel like we each have our part to
play and yeah and I am lucky enough to
have a platform so
hope to use it in the right way tick
tock
[Music]
why didn't you use a hauled cap I'm a
assuming that means a bald cap bald caps
look really fake and it was actually
really cool and liberating to shave my
head I have to say all that stopping and
going and stopping and going for a film
as complex as Black Swan must have been
excruciating yes that's actually totally
true emotionally it was really hard I
think the dancers weren't expecting to
have to repeat as much as they had to
for filming and I think it was really
hard on them physically since when was
Natalie a soccer fan so cool yeah it's
definitely unexpected for me I'm not
athletic at all I have not really had a
huge interest in sports and then I was
so energized by the women in the last
Women's World Cup when I saw my son
wanting his repino jersey I realized
that it could be such an incredible
culture shift if kids had female
athletes to look up to in the same way
that they had male athletes then the
athletes are there and they're already
very popular but they're not being
valued the way they deserve to be okay
that's it I am signing off the internet